foreign
and Fresno what's up Glenn
how's it going Dr John partying dude
what are you doing
ah talking to you sweet that's such a
great answer well played all right so
what's up dude
hey uh you know I guess just kind of
came up with this thought and
but you know email your show and
I guess you know how do you let go of
who you thought you were in this image
you had of yourself and this image that
other people implanted in yet
when you know your your life has done an
absolute 180 and
you're
your objective mind knows you're not
that stuff anymore but you know
something inside of you just can't let
it go man give me an example
well you know I used to be an overweight
kid I was the one that was always picked
last for Sports in the whole nine yards
I was shy
quiet and you know now I'm
fit um
actually I guess you could say Jack I
mean I you have a hard time have a hard
time saying something positive about
myself you know uh you know I've become
a certified personal trainer a nutrition
coach from your buddy Dr Norton and it's
you know and I'm like yeah no no
I'm I'm I'm gonna be fat again who who's
gonna want to listen to me who's going
to want to believe me yeah you know that
type thing it's just
that's one example I went through a
pretty pretty rough marriage pic
pick somebody who probably wasn't a good
partner but I learned a lot out of it
that ended
you know just recently this wonderful
woman walked into my life and I'm like
yeah she's gonna figure me out this is
this can't be real and you know I'm
sitting here awake at night thinking
what am I going to do to screw this up
what am I going to do to sabotage it why
in the world can I believe I'm worth all
this stuff
so there's um man and Her Name Escapes
me she's from London
um
she's a researcher on imposter syndrome
and
that's such a Cheesy line like at this
point in my life I'm like dude just get
over imposter syndrome but she gave a
definition that stuck with me she said
imposter syndrome is when you believe
others are are judging you as harshly as
you judge yourself
and the reason that was important for me
was imposter Syndrome has nothing to do
with the outside world it has to do with
me
right right and that's both terrifying
and relieving because I this is a situ
this is something I have to enter into
and I want you to be really grateful for
your mind and body because they're
working exactly as they should
here's why
your Bot you've been through hell
you've been the little fat kid that
everybody made fun of you've been that
little kid that had to hide in his shell
you've been the guy that girls walk past
over and over and over and over again
and your body put a GPS pin in that and
said that was terrifying and lonely and
scary we were all alone we can never let
that happen again
and so what your sweet brain and mind
and body are doing to you are just
trying to remind you that there are
sharks out there that can get us at any
moment
and now you've got a whole new world but
the GPS system is still beeping at you
right it's still trying to get your
attention hey yeah we could die we could
die we could die and so at some point
you got to make peace with a body's just
trying to keep me alive and that's
different than going to war trying to
shut up the voices
you see what I'm saying right and this
is hard especially for somebody who has
been out of shape and is now in shape
because you often have to it you often
attack that right it's like you know
pain is weakness leaving the body like
I'm gonna Crush my way through this
thing and it's discipline over and over
this is a totally this is making peace
this is opening your hands up not
tightening them up okay
um I will tell you and Lane and I have
had this conversation personally I've
had this conversation um I've been
blessed in my career to have in this new
second chapter of my life is like a
co-host a radio show with Dave Ramsey
and we talk about often off air just as
as friends
he still has
he's got hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars of net worth
he still has that poor East Tennessee
kid in there
yeah right and as my life has changed I
can't even scratch and sniff his net
worth but as my life has changed from
being the poor kid money was was a was a
curse in my home right it was terrifying
um
I've gone back to him and said hey man
how do you balance this man because I
got this little kid in me screaming it's
all coming down it's all coming down and
he's given me two um important important
things number one
in his words the ratios in my words the
charts and graphs I've got to look at
the data
okay so what I mean by that is
um if
you have ten thousand dollars and you
buy a thousand dollar car
and you have a million dollars and you
buy a hundred thousand dollar car
the ratios are the same right right in
my little brain I'm like a hundred
thousand dollar car that's right and so
it doesn't ever work and so for you
that girl would never talk to me because
I'm not worthy of her time or attention
or love
and now she does
and I have to say no no no no be and by
the way forget the jacked part
you're a guy who walks around this head
held high who loves other people who
takes care of it you dedicated your life
to helping other people through hard
moments that's who you are yeah it's
important to me that's right you've got
to learn to look at the ratios and say
okay the data says this I'm not going
back
and I've got to learn to love myself as
much as I ask other people to love
themselves
I've got to honor myself and so that
leads me the second thing and this has
been the key for me is this is not going
to sit well with the Bro culture okay
with the with the uh of course shouldn't
kill it's not gonna sit well with that
crew okay
but I don't care because I'm right and
they're wrong you have to Outsource some
of this to a group of friends and
community that will consistently call
you out hold you accountable and remind
you on a regular basis that you're loved
yeah okay and uh Andy Peterson here in
town uh Andy Peterson here in town he's
a musician here in town he says your
community defines your calling your
communities are going to be the group
that rallies around you says hey man
you're really doing a great job taking
care of people you inspire me I love you
and I've got to learn to listen to that
voice as data more than the voice in my
head saying hey it's all coming down
it's all coming down
yeah does that make sense yeah yeah yeah
the other thing is the other thing
that's hard is you know when you you you
do these these big changes you get
yourself on the right track and even in
the work world and I'm pretty high up in
a pretty major company you know dealing
with tens of millions of dollars and
it's like they're trusting some little
redneck kid from Fresno you know to do
this and but you you you're your sport
group your your friends your your close
people they
they drift away because you just can't
connect anymore so yeah you do you find
yourself kind of alone out there you in
in the so people often look at all right
what's the external work to do what can
I go crush and kill
the challenge here and there is a place
for that and make no mistake there's a
place for getting up and grinding and
working really hard there's a place for
getting up and working out really hard
and and getting in shape all that stuff
taking care of your diet taking control
of your diet stuff that lane has
personally helped me with tremendously
um but the other side of it is
ah this sucks I gotta go make new
friends at 30. yeah which is the worst
the worst the worst
right and then God forsake like you
gotta make go make friends at 40.
and the practice of our life is you only
have a certain number of opportunities
to make 25-year friends because you only
have so long to live right and so the
practice is less about I need to get my
brain to stop doing X Y and Z I need to
go make a couple of really close friends
that I can trust
yeah and that means I'm gonna have to
call guys and be weird and they may
totally hose me or I might find out six
months in oh they just using me for my
business contacts that's cool man that
they're not in a good place to be good
friends that's cool I'm not even going
to sweat it I'm just going to roll off
and go do my thing
and I'm gonna grieve it I'm gonna be
bummed out because I like that dude or I
like them cool I'm gonna go make friends
another way I'm gonna get I'm gonna have
people over my house to watch the fights
and two or three of those dudes and I
are gonna be hanging out after does that
make sense like it's gonna be a and by
the way these aren't guys at the gym
like I'm just not gonna surround myself
with Meatheads I'm gonna find a
bricklayer and a my two closest friends
on the planet my if I say four my four
closest friends right now if I was just
to tick them off one of them is a bank
examiner one of them runs it is a CEO of
a HVAC company like a plumbing HVAC
company one sells Lube I wish I was
lying you know how many cut down Wars he
wins zero because he's a Lube salesman
like for for diesel mechanic or whatever
and then the fourth one is the CEO of a
lawn care company and I'm a YouTuber
dude none of us do the same stuff
but these are guys that I regularly call
that we talk to I tell them I love them
they tell me they love me they ask about
my kids if I've got a hard life decision
I reach out to them so I've got to have
those guys they're not in my industry
they don't know the things I'm going
through every day and I don't know what
crap they're dealing with every day and
that's the beauty of it I mean and we
all all of us are different politically
we all have different Financial
situations it's just a grouping it's
just a gang and man these guys all came
later on in my life and it's been kind
of weird and kind of awkward and kind of
hard and there's 40 other dudes that I
love and care about but these ones are
so you see what I'm saying
another close friend that's in in
Colorado Springs is a Trader got another
close friend in Dallas who sells
insurance so it's it's again it
continues to Ripple and spread that's my
life's work and let me challenge you on
one more thing
you probably tell your folks you gotta
have a baseline you gotta write stuff
down is that fair
yeah yeah you guys you got to be
accurate meticulous and and you know if
it's not on paper you don't know what's
happening there you go so
um I want you to look at this on YouTube
I'm holding it up right now
I've got carry it with me it's on my
desk it's my little uh
it's a diary is what it is it's I wish I
I again I'm trying to come up with like
some red like Jocko way of saying it
like this is my this is my thought
executioner I don't it's just a diary
it's just a journal right
um
but I do I've got red I got like my
goruck sticker Christensen B Wilder
Montana knife code like I tried to make
it as tough as possible dude it's a
diary and you've got to begin to take
captive these thoughts that tell you
that you suck
okay
okay and when you have that thought that
like what are they doing like I am a
redneck kid from write that thought down
as though it's a
a a box of Girl Scout cookies you just
annihilated and you're trying to get
your handle on your nutrition write it
down and take captive of it that's not
true
I was a redneck little kid and I worked
my butt off to get here and they
wouldn't be trusting me with this if
they didn't think they were going to
make a whole bunch more money because
I'm running the show awesome
that woman is blessed to be on measure
not to marry some super sexy Glenn which
good for you
um people often mistake me as a personal
trainer too by the way and
that's never happened not one time not
one time in my life if someone been like
are you a personal trainer that's never
happened
um but she's really really lucky to meet
a guy and fall in love with a guy who's
dedicated his life
to helping other people achieve their
goals achieve their visions of Health
and Longevity and being able to wrestle
with their grandkids when they're 80.
that's work you're doing and she's she's
won the lottery falling in love with a
guy like that
yeah that's what she says it's hard for
me to grasp them yeah okay she might be
lying to you just because you're a smoke
show I don't I don't even know you I'm
not gonna lie to you nah she she she's
pretty awesome it's like I woke up and
it's like this this is different
yes so write them down
and uh I'll even give you one more thing
uh this is something me my wife you like
a tool we use all the time I did it last
night
um I asked her the question
I say hey the story I'm making up is
you're mad the story I'm making up is
you were frustrated by something I said
or did the story I'm making up is you
don't want to go to this party that we
got invited to and by saying it that way
I'm not saying why are you mad why don't
you want to go to this party I am taking
ownership of this I am created a story
in my head that you don't want to do
this and it invites her in to say you're
right I don't want to go and I had a
story that I didn't that you would be
mad or of course I want to go I just
have had diarrhea all day and I don't no
that's not my wife but but you know you
know what I mean so that's a tool you
can ask when you find yourself
I don't think she really likes me like I
can't believe
then I think you can reach out and say
hey uh the story I'm choosing to tell
myself is that a beautiful woman like
you is gonna leave a Loser Like Me
call her out
and she might look at you and say
everyone hear that story again because
it's not true
it's awesome to know you Glenn
um thank you for loving people in your
community and for dedicating your life
to other people's lives that's amazing
I want you to treat you as good as you
treat them take captive of those
thoughts my brother take captive of them
and over time your default setting will
change from I'm just a dumb idiot
redneck kid too
I'm freaking Glenn from Fresno and I'm
doing some pretty amazing things for the
people in my world